c'est parti bien mes chers collègues
procédons aujourd'hui à l'audition de
Monsieur Laurent nounz préfet de police
préfet de la zone de défense et de
sécurité de Paris dans le cadre de la
mission d'information sur l'application
de la loi du 19 mars 2023 relative aux
Jeux olympiques et paralympiques de
2024 et portant diverses autres
dispositions je rappelle que la
commission des lois a nommé comme
rapporteur nos excellentes collègues
mesdames Agnès caniller et Marie Pierre
de la
gontere je dois excuser le président de
la commission François Noël buffet
retenu en
circonscription et qui m'a confié la
lourde charge de présider cette réunion
Monsieur le Préfet si nous vous
entendons aujourd'hui devant la
commission des lois c'est qu'il nous a
paru important d'avoir des précisions
sur la manière dont s'organisera la
circul ultion dans Paris et dans la zone
dont vous aurez la charge pendant les
Jeux Olympiques votre entretien accordé
au journal Le Parisien a suscité un
certain nombre d'interrogations sur les
restrictions à la circulation mis en
place sur leur modordalité et sur leur
base légale je rappelle que la
multiplication et l'imbrication des
dispositifs de sécurité a pu par le
passé poser question tant tant du point
de vue légal que du point de vue
pratique tout le monde pense et je pense
notamment à la finale de la Champions
League au Stade de France qui a pu
soulever quelques interrogations je vous
propose donc Monsieur le Préfet de faire
une présentation des dispositifs prévus
après quoi nos rapporteurs pourront vous
poser des questions puis les sénateurs
qui en feront la demande je vous
rappelle que cette audition fera l'objet
d'une captation
vidéo qui sera retransmise en direct sur
le site internet du Sénat Monsieur le
Préfet
merci beaucoup monsieur le monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs donc je je vais donc présenter
donc la la l'audition à l'origine était
plus basée sur les Jos mais je comprends
que l'actualité la recentre sur la
question des périmètres de sécurité et
de
circulation dans Paris mais pas que hein
puisque hier nous avons j'ai donné
effectivement une interview au journal
Le Parisien et nous avons communiqué
avec la maire de Paris le président du
cojot Tony estangué et le maire de
Saint-Denis puisque Saint-Denis est une
ville qui ensine s est particulièrement
concerné avec le village olympique avec
le Stade de France et la piscine la
piscine olympique euh nous avons
communiqué donc sur les périmètres de
sécurité et de circulation applicable
sur l'ensemble de l'agglomération
parisienne viendront dans quelques jours
maintenant la présentation des mêmes
périmètres pour les sites qui sont
situés en cemarne et dans les evvelines
pour lesquels nous allons mettre en
forme les cartes un peu comme nous
l'avons fait et présenté hier pour
l'agglomération parisienne à savoir
enfin concerné par les jeux à savoir
donc le les département des des hautes
scèes de scè saint-n et et Paris euh
donc ce que nous avons présenté hier
c'est plusieurs choses hein je je je
l'ai expliqué dans le détail dans un
conférence de presse qui s'est tenue à
15h hein c'est c'est plusieurs choses
c'est en fait les quatre périmètres qui
qui s'appliquent aux Jeux Olympiques
pour que nos nos nos concitoyens on a
une connaissance le plus en amont
possible et dans un dans un processus
qui est un processus de concertation
hein donc ces périmètres ne sont pas
définitifs et les
règles qui vont les régir ne sont pas
définitivement arrêté elles le seront à
l'issue d'une période de concertation
qui va s'ouvrir à partir de dès la
semaine proff elle a commencé en fait
puisque dès ce matin je recevais les
opérateurs des réseaux divers et variés
téléphonie gaz électricité pour discuter
de ces sujets et définir les conditions
dans lesquelles leurs opérateurs
pourront accéder ou pas au périmètrre
bon euh donc voilà et donc nous allons
continuer cette consultation sur la base
qui a été rendue publique hier pour
pouvoir entendre ce qu'on à nous dire
les principaux acteurs des territoires à
commencé par les élus évidemment mais
aussi les grands acteurs économiques les
professionnels des transports les
professionnels du bâtiment qui sont
évidemment très inquiets par par par les
nos périmètre de circulation et nous
allons dans cette phase de consultation
les rencontrer très régulièrement en
tout cas entendre leurs observations sur
ces périmètres
alors donc ça c'est important à rappeler
on est dans une phase de consultation et
évidemment et d'ailleurs je je le dis
d'emblé pour se lever tout malentendu
cette consultation qui va durer jusqu'à
la mi-janvier environ donnera lieu à un
arbitrage définitif sur les règles des
périmètres qui vont donner lieu à la
prise par le préfet de police d'arrêter
hein donc il vont arrêter ces périmètres
il y aura des mesures de police
administrative euh pour lesquels comme
vous le savez je suis compétent sur
toute l'île- de- France pendant les jeux
mais donc que je pourrais évidemment
déléger à au préfet de département et en
tout état de cause ces périmètres
interviendront seront fixés sans doute
un un peu avant les Jeux donc ce seront
sans doute les préfets qui les prendront
mais sur une base que nous avons
communément arrêté hein donc l'ensemble
des préfet île- de- France nous nous
sommes mis d'accord sur les principes
que je vais vous donner et surtout les
principes dérogatoires c'est ça qui est
le plus important et c'est ça qui
interroge c'est ça qui va qui a conduit
à au débat qu'il a eu hier sur la
fameuse plateforme c'est c'est les
conditions de dérogation d'accès à
certains périmètres alors il y a quatre
périmètres hein il y a quatre périmètres
bon B je je les cartes sont en ligne he
sur le site du du des des sur notre site
sur le site du cojot sur le site de la
Ville de Paris je pense que de
nombreuses communes feront ensuite la
même chose et mettront ses cartes en
ligne il y a un périmètre qui est le
périmètre organisateur qui est un
périmètre qui est très restreint qui
concerne le site soit le site de
compétition soit le site soit le le le
site village
olympique un site le le le Trocadero par
exemple qui sera un site où va se
dérouler la cérémonie ouverture euh et
puis euh et puis il y a d'autres une
deux autres catégories de sites
importants il y a les courses les
courses en ligne hein donc il y a des
courses cyclistes il y a un marathon il
y a un triathlon il y a un certain
nombre de courses qui vont se tenir et
qui vont se tenir sur un périmètre en
général assez assez long et sur lequel
évidemment euh il y aura un périmètre
également de de de protection bon euh et
puis encadrant la course et puis euh j'y
reviendrai à la fin parce que en soi
c'est un sujet il y a la question de la
cérémonie d'ouverture à Paris évidemment
donc le périmètre organisateur c'est le
périmètre qui qui entoure directement le
site olympique bon c'est le premier
périmètre celui-ci il est à la main
complète de l'organisateur c'est le COJO
qui gère ce périmètre il y a un deuxième
périmètre c'est le périmètre de
protection qui est le périmètre de la
Loi antiterroriste hein
euh qui est un périmètre sur lequel qui
est qui est contrôlé par les forces de
l'ordre et qui vise évidemment à éviter
que des individus ne se rendent sur un
site olympique armé ou avec des
intentions de commettre une action
terroriste he c'est les périmètres de la
loi de 2017 euh donc qui a été a été
prolongé comme vous le savez et donc ces
périmètres silt nous permettent de faire
des contrôles aux entrées et notamment
des des fouilles hein palpation qui sont
faites à l'entrée du périmètre et en
général sur l'ensemble des sites ces
périmètres correspondent au périmètre
organisateur en général il y a quelques
sites où on aura dririn ou des commerces
quelques-uns et il y a le cas
particulier mais je le mets
volontairement de côté et le ministre en
a d'ailleurs parlé ce matin sur France 2
il y a le cas de la cérémonie
d'ouverture où le périmètre de
protection antiterroriste sera plus
large que le périmètre de l'organisateur
qui est en fait la la parade et les
kebas de la scne ça ce sera le pour la
cérémonie d'ouverture le périmètre
organisateur mais j'y reviendrai et puis
il y a deux autres périmètres donc alors
les périmètres dont je viens de parler
organisateurs périmètres antiterroristes
sont des périmètres qui sont des
périmètres qui régissent l'accès piéton
également évidemment on ne rentre pas
dans ces périmètres comme on veut et ce
qui est normal bon ces périmètres sont
tout à fait classiques on les pratique à
chaque compétition quand il y a un match
au Parc des Princes il y a un périmètre
de protection il y a un match de foot
périmètre organisateur c'est le PSG
quand il y a un match au Stade de France
c'est ce qu'on fait pendant toute la
Coupe du monde de rugby c'est ce que
nous avons fait et puis il y a
évidemment ensuite deux autres
périmètres qui qui F c'est le 3è et le
4e ce sont des périmètres dit de
circulation le premier est un périmètre
d'interdiction de circulation c'est on
interdit la circulation pourquoi ben
parce qu'on considère que pour des par
mesure de sécurité hein donc c'est une
zone de sécurité j'y reviendrai c'est
très important de comprendre ça c'est un
périmètre où on restreint la circulation
pourquoi parce que il y a énormément de
de flux de piétons qui parce qu'il se
rendent au site de compétition qui parce
qu'ils se rendent à la cérémonie d'
ouverture qui parce qu'il se rendent
voir une course de de cycliste B vont
emprunter ses rues en flux piétonnier et
puis il y a aussi un du passage motorisé
puisque il y a tous les véhicules du
cojot les livreurs les prestataires
voilà ce sont des zone où il y aura une
circulation à la fois déjà assez dense
avec l'organisateur et puis des flux de
piéton et très dense avec un risque
important et j'insiste c'est un
périmètre de sécurité avec un risque
important de voiture bélier Si on ne
procédait pas des contrôles très
clairement bon donc ce périmètre est un
périmètre par principe d'interdiction de
circulation dans la vraie vie quand on
en fait des manifestations à Paris on
prévoit aussi toujours ces périmètres de
circulation pendant la coupe du monde de
rugby il y avait ces périmètres de
circulation ils existaient sauf que la
Coupe du monde de rugby c'est l'espace
d'un match c'est un petit peu moins long
euh là on parle de sites de compétition
qui vont parfois être activés tous les
jours pendant 15 jours bon et puis
ensuite il y a la scène la séquence des
paralympiques qui va vont se dérouler à
peu près sur les mêmes scènes donc le
principe de cette de ce périmètre c'est
interdiction de circulation sauf que à
l'inverse de ce que nous faisons
d'habitude nous avons prévu énormément
de dérogations à cette à cette
interdiction de circulation alors je
précise bien les choses je parle de
circulation routière motorisée hein
c'est ça qui est interdit c'est-à-dire
que les piétons peuvent évidemment
passer et les vélos peuvent également
circuler dans ces périmètres
d'interdiction de circulation on ne
parle que de la circulation routière et
contrairement à ce que nous faisons
d'habitude parce que c'est les jeux
olympiqu les Jeux Olympiques et parce
qu'à la fois il faut qu'on arrive à
concilier cet impératif de sécurité avec
cet impératif qui fait que bah dans ces
zoneslà il y a des gens qui vivent que
la contrainte elle n'est pas que sur une
journée elle est sur 15 jours et puis
ensuite elle se renouvelle 15 jours
après avec les Jeux paralympiques entre
donc je vous rappelle les dates he 26
juillet euh on on 6 juillet 11 août et
puis on repart le 28 août jusqu'au 8 8
septembre je je crois je en tout cas
voilà ça ce sont les date des des des
des jeux et qui euh nous nous conduisent
quand même à des périodes
d'immobilisation de secteurs qui sont
quand même assez longs donc il nous
paraissait draisonnable dans ces
périmètres d'interdiction de circulation
euh de ne pas laisser entrer à titre
dérogatoire un certain nombre de véhic
vicule parce que sur ces périmètres il y
a des gens qui vivent il y a des
commerces il y a des hôtels il y a des
entreprises et donc nous avons prévu
tout un tas de dérogations qui ont été
listées qui ont été listées dans un
tableau qui a été mis en ligne et qui
est mis à disposition du public et des
grands acteurs qu' vont pouvoir
consulter et sur la base de duquel va se
dérouler cette concertation parce que la
concertation qu'on ouvre en vrai elle
porte surtout sur ce sujet Quelles sont
les personnes qui seront autorisées à
rentrer dans ce périmètre d'
interdiction de circulation donc il a il
y a toute une catégorie de de de
personnes des taxis qui déposeraient des
taxis qui déposeraient des clients
résidents dans dans la zone des
résidents qui disposeraient de parking
privés des personnes ayant loué des
chambres dans des hôtels et qui
disposent de parking privé euh des
personnes qui donnent de de de des
médecins euh des personnes qui vont
visiter des proches vulnérables voilà
autant de dérogations dont on a essayé
de les faire correspondre à la vraie vie
des gens et à la vraie vie personnelle
et à la vraie vie économique des gens
donc il y a toute une liste qui a
vocation éventuellement à être complétée
éventuellement même à être
élargi donc en fonction de la
consultation qui va s'engager je
reviendrai sur les modalités de contrôle
puisque c'est ce qui pose problème mais
je précise que ce périmètre il est
matérialisé c'est pas un périmètre
fictif il sera tenu par les forces de
l'ordre donc il y aura des barrages de
forces de l'ordre qui laisseront passer
les gens évidemment moi je souhaite que
ça se passe de la façon la plus fluide
possible la plus fluide possible j'y
reviendrai également donc et puis on a
un dernier périmètre un 4ème périmètre
autour des sites hein donc qui apparaît
sur les cartographies qui ont été mises
en ligne c'est le périmètre bleu alors
lui le périmètre bleu c'est pas un
périmètre d'interdiction de circulation
c'est un périmètre où on réglemente la
circulation en clair c'est un périmètre
sur lequel nous souhaitons éviter la
circulation de transit c'estàd qu'on ne
veut pas que ce soit un périmètre ou ce
soit une circulation de passage
c'est-à-dire d'individus qui vont d'un
point A à un point B qui n'est pas dans
ce périmètre bleu qui ne soit pas dans
ce périmètre bleu éviter qu'il qu'ils y
passent donc ce périmètre euh et on
pourra lui en revanche il y a pas de il
y a pas de il y a pas de dérogation
c'est plutôt pris à l'inverse c'est
plutôt un périmètre dans lequel on peut
circuler sauf lorsqu'on est en transit
bon et donc là aussi il y aura des
forces de l'ordre il y aura pas de
barrage aussi ferme que pour le
périmètre d'interdiction de circulation
mais il y aura des contrôles qui nous
permettront de vérifier qu'une personne
n'est pas en transit ce sera en réalité
un périmètre indicatif ce sera un
périmètre qui qui est connu maintenant
et les les les automobilistes seront
puisqueévidemment on ne parle toujours
que de circulation routière motorisée he
j'insiste à nouveau hein les piétons
circulent librement et les vélos aussi
donc ce sera un périmètre où on sera
incité finalement à éviter d'avoir à
entrer dans à entrer dans ce dans ce ce
périmètre quand on a rien à y faire par
contre tous les gens qui ont quelque
chose à y faire soit parce qu'ils y
résident soit parce que ils y
travaillent soit parce qu'ils ont des
des proches à visiter pourront y entrer
sans avoir à demander de dérogation sans
avoir à demander de dérogation donc
voilà les voilà les quatre principes
voilà les quatre périmètres alors je
précise je précise évidemment je précise
évidemment que pour les courses sur
route c'est exactement le même principe
hein donc sauf que les courses sur route
en vrai les plus contraignantes elles
ont lieu surtout euh les weekend hein on
a une course cycliste un marathon course
cycliste le 3 et le 4 août c'est un
weekend et un marathon le 10 et le 11
c'est un weekend bon donc tout ça ce
sera quand même beaucoup moins
contraignant et on est sur des plages
horair qui sont plutôt de l'ordre de la
demi-journée voire la journée pour la
course cycliste mais c'est en weekend et
vous connaissez tous le principe des
cours cyclistes he nous sommes en pleine
discussion avec le cojot ça sera aussi
discuté pendant dans dans le cadre de la
consultation nous aurons nous allons
demander à avoir énormément de points de
passage àce que de manière à ce que les
riverins puissent passer d'un point à
l'autre évidemment pas quand la course
passe euh mais ça nous sommes en
discussion avec le cojot et on en
parlera évidemment pendant la
consultation il y a une course qui
impacte qui est un peu plus impactante
c'est ça se passe pendant les Jeux
paralympiques c'est la course cycliste
en fait l'épreuve cycliste se déroule
sur le même parcours qui est en scène
saint-niis à l'est du département et qui
fait plutôt une boucle et là il y a
toutes les épreuves qui se déroulent euh
sur cette période donc je je n'ai plus
les dates en tête mais je crois que
c'est du 4 auou 7 septembre on a
plusieurs épreuves qui se déroulent donc
on aura quand même une une une une
emprise sur voie publique qui sera assez
forte et c'est sans doute là qu'il
faudra qu'on prévoit le plus de points
de passage bien évidemment alors voilà
pour l'économie générale du dispositif
je pourrais répondre après à vos
questions sur la cérémonie d'ouverture
sur le la question de la plateforme sur
la question de la plateforme il nous a
semblé que pour les périmètres
d'interdiction de circulation motorisée
dans les seuls périmètre rouge que vous
avez sous les yeux si vous consultez les
cartes pour ces seuls périmètres ça ne
concerne pas les piétons ça ne concerne
pas les vélo et ça ne concerne pas le
reste de Paris on est que dans ces
périmètres là pour ces seuls périmètres
qui sont encore une fois des pratiques
habituelles des services de police il
nous a semblé que il était sans doute
plus simple cont tenu du nombre de
dérogations que nous avons prévu de
l'importance des dérogation que nous
avons prévu il nous a paru plus simple
de faire en sorte que les personnes
concernées puissent s'enregistrer sur
une plateforme voilà l'alternative à ça
euh c'est quoi l'alternative à
l'enregistrement sur une plateforme euh
avec délivrance injustificatif
évidemment bon ce qui permet de passer
plus simple plus simplement plus
rapidement de manière plus fluide les
barrages et pour le Riverin qui habite
dans la zone il demande évidemment son
justificatif une fois et c'est terminé
et il repassera les barrages tous les
jours sans difficulté pour regagner le
parking privé de sa résidence comme tous
les rivrins pourront le faire quand ils
disposent d'un parking privé même chose
pour toutes les catégories de
dérogations h ça nous a paru plus simple
de prévoir une plateforme où on puisse
s'enregistrer à l'avance et recevoir un
justificatif donc
euh l'alternative c'est quoi
l'alternative euh en en en je le disais
hier lors du point presse euh un préfet
de police plus rigoureux pourrait dire
bon ben à ce moment-là on revient sur
les principes habituels et puis on reste
sur une restriction de circulation assez
forte finalement pourquoi on s'ennuie à
prèsvoir des dérogations si au final on
va avoir des que énormes au
barrage bon l'autre alternative
effectivement c'est quand même de
laisser rentrer les gens par dérogation
mais de leur demander des justificatifs
dont on aura pas dont on aura pas défini
en amont les règles qui vont au barrage
de police dire moi je suis Rivin mais
qui n'auront pas l'attestation qui
correspond qu' ne seront pas en mesure
de le justifier et que finalement on ne
laissera pas rentrer que finalement on
ne laissera pas rentrer donc il nous
paraissait plus simple de prévoir une
plateforme comme ça se fait assez
souvent comme comme vous le savez il y a
eu le G7 à Biaritz en 2019 c'est ce qui
a été fait c'est ce qui a été fait il y
avait une plateforme d'enregistrement
pour les Riverin de manière à pouvoir
justifier de l'accès au périmètre de
mémoire d'ailleurs à biarit ça
concernait aussi les piétons je rappelle
que je ne parle que de la circulation
routière automobile automobile voilà il
nous paraissait plus simple de prévoir
une plateforme avec justificatif papier
QR code comme j'ai pu le dire dans Le
Parisien moi j'en sais rien on va en
discuter dans la concertation on verra
ce que les gens en général les gens
préfèrent quand même les QR codes parce
que ça permet au contrôle de flasher et
les gens passent on tout ça on en
discutera en tout cas nous nous
considérons d'un point de vue
sécuritaire que ce périmètre de toute
façon est indispensable à mettre en
place nous considérons d'un point de vue
de la bonne tenue des JO et que pour les
gens puissent continuer à vivre
normalement qu'il doit y avoir des
dérogations et évidemment le triangle de
tout ça c'est qu'on puisse contrôler et
la sécurité et le le le le fait que ces
dérogations soient rigour usement
appliqué bon voilà donc voilà d'où
l'idée de cette plateforme qui enendroit
puisque c'est une question qui qui m'a
été posé
hier j'ai j'ai entendu donc des
comparaisons avec l'état d'urgence il
faut une loi et cetera bon tout le monde
se souvient que l'état d'urgence c'était
quand même des contraintes qui étaient
d'un autre niveau d'un autre niveau on
était sur des mesures où vous deviez
rester à votre domicile avec des des
contrainte pénale pénale moi la
contrainte qu'il y a à mes périmètres de
circulation c'est que vous rentrez pas
c'est c'est tout vous garez votre
voiture et vous rentrez à pied hein donc
avec des contraintes pénales une série
de mesures qui étaient beaucoup plus
restrictives il ne s'agissa il ne
s'agissait pas de il ne s'agissait pas
évidemment de de de d'un simple une
simple
restriction le fait de pénétrer en
véhicule dans une zone et puis l'état
d'urgence c'était une mesure qui était
évidemment applicable sur l'ensemble du
territoire national là où on ne pas
parle que de quelques zones dans Paris
évidemment dans l'ensemble de la région
Île-de-France autour des autres sites
mais ailleurs qu'à Paris l'impact est
moindre il faut faut j'ai oublié de
préciser ça c'est très important à Paris
l'impact est important parce qu'il y a
des sites éphémères qui vont avoir une
surface plus importante bon il reste il
reste de faible ampleur mais il est plus
important que les sites d'autres régions
et je mets encore volontairement de côté
c'est pour ça que le maire de
Saint-Denis hier était à nos côté je
mets volontairement de côté
le le la situation de la commune de de
saint-nis donc le cadre juridique dans
lequel s'inscrit cette plateforme à à à
mettre en place c'est celui d'un arrêté
qui a déjà été soumis à l'acnil qui est
un arrêté du 2 2011 relatif au
traitement automatisé de données à
caractère personnel dé nommés fichiers
des résidents des zones de sécurité créé
à l'occasion d'un événement majeur donc
ça c'est un arrêté dont nous faisons
usage quand il y a ce ce type
d'événement nous sommes bien dans le
cadre d'un événement majeur il s'agit
bien de réglementer l'accès à une zone
d'ailleurs je vais vous en lire le
contenu parce que ce sera beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus simple donc le directeur
général de la police nationale le
directeur général de la de la
gendarmerie nationale et le préfet de
police sont autorisés à mettre en œuvre
des traitements de données à caractère
personnel dénommés fichiers des
résidents de zon de sécurité ayant pour
finalité la gestion des titres
permettant l'accès des personnes ou des
véhicules aux ZES à l'intérieur
desquelles sont apporté des restrictions
à la libre circulation à l'exercice de
certaines activités afin de prévenir les
troubles à l'ordre public et de garantir
la sécurité d'un événement majeur voilà
c'est cet arrêté que nous appliquons qui
prévoit la catégorie des données
personnelles évidemment que nous pouvons
collecter
enregistré et et qui que nous appliquons
qui avait été appliqué à Biaritz que
nous allons appliquer à cette occasion
en quelque sorte cette zone de
circulation d'interdiction de
circulation ça devient une zone de
sécurité hein c'est une zone de sécurité
au sein de laquelle je vais restreindre
la circulation automobile sauf la
circulation motorisée pardon sauf pour
les catégories d'exception que je vais
donner voilà voilà donc ça c'est le le
le texte qui est en vigueur bon je je
j'ai entendu aussi beaucoup de choses he
sur là mais tout ça évidemment moi je
suis ouvert au débat il y a pas de
difficulté hein beaucoup de de de de
remarques aussi sur quelle est la
bascule qui fait que on passe d'un donc
d'abord le traitement qu'on propose il
est il existe il est autorisé par un
arrêté qui a été vu par l'acnine que les
choses soient bien claires c'est la
situation actuelle et je n'ai pas
l'intention de m'éloigner des conditions
qui sont fixées dans cet arrêté et qui
correspondent parfaitement à nos besoins
on n pas besoin de recueillir énormément
d'informations juste ce qu'il faut pour
être certain que la personne a quelque
chose à faire dans la zone où elle se
rend parce qu'elle y a un intérêt parce
qu'elle y travaille parce qu'elle y est
domiciliée parce qu'elle se rend même
peut-être dans un un restaurant qui est
situé dans cette zone et que ce
restaurant a un parking et qu'elle peut
rentrer en véhicule donc euh je je je je
rappelle hein que l'exigence d'une loi
quand on met en place ce type de
traitement enfin le le Conseil d'État
dans son avis dans l'avis qu'il a rendu
à l'époque sur l'état d'urgence
sanitaire avait bien rappelé hein
que que dans donc l'arrêté pardon 2011
est pris en application de la l 78 he
évidemment euh que le Conseil d'État
avait relevé que cette loi de 78
déterminer les conditions générales dans
lesquelles peut-être autorisé un
traitement de donné la création d'El tel
traitement même lorsqu'il est mis en
œuvre par une personne publique et qu'il
est d'une ampleur importante nécessite
pas en principe l'intervention du
législateur mais uniquement un acte
réglementaire c'est ce qui a été fait
avec cet arrêté de 2011 donc le cadre
juridique on n' même pas à le prendre il
existe évidemment je je vous annonce que
je je tout ce que je vous dis là je
j'échangerai avec laacnil hein
évidemment he d'ailleurs d'ailleurs j'ai
j'auris un contact récent avec laacnil
la dlpsi a des contacts réguliers avec
laacnil sur tous ces sujets pour
échanger avec eux et donc il était
rappelé dans ce même avis du Conseil
d'État que le recours à une loi est
cependant nécessaire dans l'hypothèse où
le traitement envisagé ne peut-être mise
en œuvre sans modification d'une
disposition législative qui fait
obstacle ce qui n'est pas le cas ainsi
que dans celle où le traitement conduit
à fixer des règles concernant les droits
civiques et les garanties fondamentales
accordé aux citoyens pour l'exercice des
libertés publiques et entre ainsi dans
le champ de l'article 34 ce qui n'est
pas le cas du dispositif que nous
mettons en œuvre he ce qui n'est pas le
cas en tout cas à mes yeux du dispositif
que nous mettons en œuvre donc voilà
pour les bases juridiques de ce
dispositif j'en termine quand même avec
la cérémonie d'ouverture qui est un d'un
genre un peu particulier mais qui va
utiliser finalement le même dispositif
juridique pour la cérémonie d'ouverture
on va utiliser le même dispositif
juridique parce qu'on est sur un
événement
majeur donc ce sera le même même
dispositif à la nuance prês que nous
allons avoir un périmètre qui va qui va
aussi concerner les piétons alors il ne
s'agira pas évidemment d'imposer des des
restrictions mais le ministre l'a
rappelé sur France 2 ce matin pour des
des raisons évidentes de contrôle et de
sécurité il est bien évident que pour
les personnes qui rentreront dans le
périmètre de protection anti le
périmètre antiterroriste de la cérémonie
d'ouverture que nous mettrons en place
comme nous l'avons annoncé c'est
quelques jours avant sans donner encore
évidemment le le moment de sa mise en
œuvre pour des raisons évidentes de
sécurité évidemment que dans cette zone
contrairement à ce qui va être fait sur
les périmètres rouges et les périmètres
de circulation routière automobile
motorisé nous allons également mettre en
place un contrôle que j'ai annoncé hier
sans en donner les modalités Paris qu'il
a une phase de concertation qui s'ouvre
pour la cérémonie d'ouverture il y a des
mers d'arrondissement il y a la mer de
Paris avec laquelle je doit évidemment
discuter nous mettrons évidemment en
place un périmètre qui tout en
permettant aux personnes d'accéder au
périmètre de la cérémonie d'ouverture
évidemment bah sauf le jour de la
cérémonie où il faut avoir un billet
mais en dehors de ces de ce jour de la
cérémonie quelques jours avant il y aura
un contrôle qui portera aussi sur les
piétons dont le le le le les modalités
ne sont pas encore déterminées donc nous
verrons ça pendant la consultation mais
qui va reposer sur le même cadre
juridique que celui que je viens
d'exposer hein voilà ce sera on va on
les les gens devront probablement
s'enregistrer pour se rendre dans
certains lieux sur le le périmètre de la
cérémonie alors encore une fois ce sont
des règles qui sont on retrouve bien là
le même équilibre que celui que nous
recherchons c'estàdire à la fois des
règles de
sécurité je vous cache pas je pense
qu'il n'y a pas une délégation étrangère
et parmi les plus grandes sans doute
très certainement qui qui qui
comprendrait que on laisse des gens
cheminer sur le périmètre de la
cérémonie d'ouverture sans qu'il y ait
un contrôle je je pense que ça n'existe
pas je vous rassure enfin ça n'existe
pas les les gens vont tous nous dire oh
là là mais c'est français comment ils
font ça donc voilà donc il faut il faut
qu'on ait un périmètre de sécurité qui
soit robuste solide c'est le cas il est
bâti il est dessiné dans les cartes que
nous avons produites les modalités
d'accès ne sont pas encore les modalités
d'accès piéton ne sont pas encore
déterminées évidemment nous nous les
connaissons mais il faut qu'on qu'on
concerte qu'on discute euh mais personne
ne comprendrait que on laisse rentrer
les gens mais en même temps on les
laissera on laisse rentrer les gens sans
contrôle mais par contre on les laissera
évidemment rentrer pourquoi parce que
dans ce périmètre bah il y a des gens
qui vivent il y a des commerces il y a
des restaurants il y a des entreprises
et donc il y a plein de raisons qui font
que on ne va pas empêcher de circuler
sur cette zone sauf que il faudra là
encore probablement s'enregistrer on des
livroir dans un justificatif dans des
modalité qu'on va définir et le ministre
l'a rappelé ce matin d'ailleurs sur
France 2 mais la base juridique la base
juridique ce sera exactement la même
voilà donc on n'est pas sur une
restriction majeure sur une atteinte
telle à une garantie fondamentale que il
ne nous semble pas qu'il soit nécessaire
de prendre une loi nous avons un arrêté
qui régit les zones de sécurité encore
une fois qui sont définis par par mes
arrêtés hein et qui sont prévus donc par
un arrêté de 2011 spécifiquement pour
les grands événements et chaque fois
qu'on veut restreindre l'accès au
périmètres de ces grands événements pour
des raisons de sécurité voilà on est
pile dans ce cadre moi je je n'ai rien
inventé hein donc évidemment et je l'ai
dit je vous le redis j'en terminerai par
là monsieur le Président j'étais un peu
long mais le sujet méritait sans doute
ce développement j'ai été un peu long
mais évidemment moi je suis tout à fait
disposé quand on aura terminé la
consultation dans laquelle évidemment
nous avons prévu de rencontrer les deux
chambres hein je je voilà donc on doit
se rapprocher des directeurs de cabinet
des deux présidents pour voir avec eux
quel selon quelle modalité il souhait
qu'on leur présente dans le détail le
dispositif mais c'est moins de présenter
parce que présenter vousz vous l'avez en
ligne que de recueillir un certain
nombre d'observation mais qui vont être
très pratiau pratique moi peut-être que
le président du Sénat ou ses
collaborateurs me diront mais attendez
comment j'accède à tel endroit comment
je est-ce que on aura la possibilité de
et c'est un peu ça l'objet des échanges
qu'on va avoir moi je suis évidemment
tout disposé à venir évidemment vous
rencontrez une fois que nous aurons fini
cette concertation qui englobera encore
une fois le Sénat et l'Assemblée
nationale moi je suis prêt à venir vous
présenter avant qu'il ne soit rendu
public présenter à la mission dont c'est
l'objet le suivi des JO je suis
évidemment prêt à venir vous présenter
le dispositif tel qu'il aura été
définitivement arrêté avant que nous le
fassions à la presse puisque nous avons
convenu hier avec Madame Idalgo monsieur
Estanguet et le maire de Saint-Denis et
c'est ce que feront les préfets dans
leur département nous avons prévu
évidemment de rendre ensuite public le
dispositif définitivement arrêté de
gestion de nos périmètres voilà ce que
je voulais vous dire Monsieur le
Président avant de répondre à vos
questions merci Monsieur le Préfet
mesdames les
rapporteurs
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Préfet de Police juste avant en guise de
préembule rappelez quand même que cette
audition était prévue dans le cadre de
notre mission de suivi de l'application
de la loi sur la sécurisation des Jeux
Olympique avant vos annonces hier faites
à la presse et en conférence de presse
et que donc nous avons ces travaux dans
le cadre de nos missions de contrôle de
l'application des lois qui sont dévolue
à au Parlement premièrement de
deuxièmement et donc du coup on a
évidemment de nombreuses questions à
vous poser Monsieur le Préfet de police
sur l'organisation de ces Jeux
Olympiques dont la date approche et le
compte à rebours est largement engagé
mais c'est vrai que vous annonce
concernant les zones de périmètres qui
étaient attendu notamment sur la
cérémonie d'ouverture étant donné le
caractère
exceptionnel je rappelle en d'une
cérémonie d'ouverture qui aura lieu à
l'extérieur ce qui ne s'est jamais vu
sans dans n'étant pas dans un lieu
contraint et qui se déroulera le long
d'un fleuve et donc la sécurisation de
cette cérémonie d'ouverture suscitait
beaucoup d'attentes et vous avez en
partie répondu même si nous avons encore
un certain nombre de de questions les
les annonces que vous avez faites hier
soulèvent pour nous déjà un certain
certaines questions relatives à
l'imbrication des différents périmètres
nous comprenons les bases légales entre
les périmètres de la loi silt dont la
finalité avant tout la lutte contre le
terrorisme plus les périmètres de
sécurisation de l'ordre publici et de
sécurisation routière nous avons un peu
de mal à voir comment tout cela va
s'imbriquer notamment en matière de
contrôle sachant que les degrés
d'atteinte aux liberté sont variables
entre des périmètres silt où les
fouilles seront possibles et où il y
aura un contrôle systématique à l'entrée
et les périmètres notamment rouges ou
sur lesquels pourront circuler de
manière motorisée que ceux qui ont une
autorisation avec ces fameuses QR codes
ou formme d'autorisation pas encore
totalement
définies et donc première question c'est
comment concrètement cela va s'imbriquer
comment va passer d'un niveau à l'autre
et quel et et premièrement deuxièmement
euh qu'en est-il par des des d'autres
zones qui vont exister comme cell des
fan zones qui était un sujet aussi de
contrôle celle de notamment relative à
la flamme olympique doncon appelle tout
le parcours de la flamme olympique
avez-vous prévu aussi des modalités de
de sécurisation sur la concertation vous
avez parlé de concertation notamment sur
euh les dérogations ou ceux qui seront
autorisés à circuler dans ces zones
dites rouges il y aura-t-il aussi une
concertation sur les périmètres précis
de ces de ces zones et de ces périmètres
définis et puis j'ai une dernière
question par rapport à ce sujet-là parce
que évidemment j'en aurai aussi sur la
vidéo protection intelligente qui est un
gros sujet qui concerne cette
sécurisation mais sur lequel nous
reviendrons sûrement plus tard sur les
autorisations pour accéder aux zone
quels seront les contrôles et notamment
pour l'obtention du fameux QR code
d'autorisation d'accès à cette zone
rouge voà mes premières questions madame
de La
Gonterie merci président merci Monsieur
le Préfet de toutes vos explications je
crois que en fait le le comment dire le
l'intérêt j'allis dire les mois pour
certains l'intérêt de de vos annonces
d'hier c'est
que chacun a pris conscience de manière
assez brutal de ce que ça voulait dire
que d'organiser des Jeux Olympiques dans
une ville euh et tout à coup le principe
de réalité a fait que on a réalisé un
certain nombre de choses
euh pour ma part je pense que évidemment
tous les dispositifs de sécurité de
contrôle sont sont non seulement
justifiés mais nécessaires et attendus
euh reste à voir ensuite comment comment
il s'organise je n'ai pas extrêmement
bien compris
euh votre votre explication concernant
la stabilité juridique du dispositif
parce que vous faites référence donc une
loi qui est assez ancienne alors que le
périmètre silt par principe ne peut
s'appliquer que en vertu de la Loi silt
de 2017 donc j'imagine qu'il va donc y
avoir un nouveau décret et donc une
nouvelle saisine de l'acnil enfin bon
autour de tout ça j'ai pas voilà
j'aimerais comprendre un peu mieux
euh et du coup euh
il me semble que ça veut dire que selon
un certain nombre de cas les piétons
aussi pourrai avoir à justifier de leur
présence et cetera et cetera dans un
certain nombre dans certain nombre de
lieux j'ai tendance à penser que
quelques explications pratiques cas
pratique explication illustration
permettrait que les gens comprennent un
peu mieux de quoi il s'agit mais ça
c'est uniquement une question de Come
c'est pas
bon voilà donc ça c'est mon
interrogation
j'ai une question plus enfin précise à à
à vous
poser depuis la loi dite Jo euh nous
avons autorisé l'usage de la
vidéosurveillance
algorithmique la presse a révél l'usage
notamment par la Préfecture de Police
sauf si c'est
inexact par le biais de ces logiciels de
vidéosurveillance algorithmique une
fonctionnalité de reconnaissance faciale
il y aur déjà eu des une condamnation
euh de la ville de de daauville sur sur
ce point euh qu'en est-il euh la
préfecture de police utilise-t-elle
cette fonctionnalité et ma dernière
question alors évidemment on parle que
circulation périmètre QR code et cetera
donc ça peut paraître un peu décalé quoi
que euh il y a une préoccupation une
question sur la capacité à recruter
insuffisamment d'agents de sécurité
privé euh
voilà on est assez on est très intéressé
aujourd'hui ou lors d'une autre audition
parce que je suis sûr que nous serons
amenés à vous
revoir de d'avoir un peu d'éléments sur
ce point leur nombre leur recrutement
leur formation et cetera et
cetera Monsieur le
Préfet merci donc je peux répondre à ces
deux premières séries de questions donc
sur le sur l'intégration des des des
périmètres l'imbrigation l'imbrication
pardon plus exactement des périmètre ils
sont de nature différentes en fait hein
donc un périmètre de circulation n'est
pas un périmètre de protection silt où
là tous les contrôles tout le monde
quand il rentre et fouillé euh
avec oui oui sur un périmètre de
protection silt le périmètre de
protection piéton bien sûr piéton oui en
véhiculeadr bleu généralement dans le
périmètre encadré bleu on ne rentre pas
en véhicule hein ce sont vraiment les
piétons qui rentrent autour du site hein
donc ce sont les piétons mais c'est
vraiment le périmètre qui est au plus
près du site hein il faut que ceux qui
nous écoutent comprennent bien qu'on ne
parle que du périmètre autour du site de
compétition et c'est ce qu'on fait
encore une fois pour la Coupe du monde
de rugby c'est ce qu'on a fait pour la
Coupe du monde de rugby c'est ce qu'on a
fait
encore avanthier pour le match
parissgermain Arsenal c'est ce qu'on
fait dans toute dans tous les événements
c'est toujours comme ça hein donc il y a
un périmètre où on est fouillé donc ça
c'est un périmètre de la loi de
2017 euh
donc chose plus vivante quand c'est à
l'occasion d'une manifestation c'est
pour accéder au stade ou que sais-je là
on va parler de quartier enfin de de
zone où les gens habite oui mais il n'y
a pas d'habitation dans le périmètre de
protection le périmètre de protection
non le périmètre antiterroriste de
protection il épouse celui du site
vraiment strictement sauf pour la
cérémonie d'ouverture hein voilà je je
le redis on le met de côté comment gris
oui c'est les zones grises oui oui et et
vous avez le le petit trait bleu qui
entoure les zones grises qui parfois
déborde
pourquoi parce qu'il y a une voix qui
arrive et qu'il faut inclure la voie
pour avir un meilleur contrôle donc
voilà donc l'abrication elle se fait
assez naturellement et tout le reste
c'est libre au piéton en fait c'est
libre d'accès on peut y approcher au
plus près le problème c'est la
circulation routière donc l'imbcation se
fait de manière assez naturel parce que
finalement ce ne sont pas du tout les
mêmes zones ce ne sont pas du tout les
mêmes zones il y a des zones de
réglementation de la sécurité et
d'autres de protection de sécurité et
d'autres qui sont aussi prises pour des
mtif de sécurité mais qui ne porte que
sur les véhicules voilà c'est vraiment
ça ce qu'on veut éviter sur la la les
fan zones oui vous avez raison de
souligner qu'il y a il y a il y aura un
certain nombre de de Fan Zone dans enfin
de c'est c'est les clubs France France
2024 qui qui seront organisés dans Paris
qui seront évidemment protégés et puis
il y en aura d'autres qui seront tenus à
l'initiative des collectivités locales
nous on souhaite en limiter le plus le
nombre parce que ça voudrait dire qu'il
faut qu'on mobilise beaucoup de
dispositifs de de de de sécurité
euh en tout cas nous n'avons pas
normalement à les protéger hein ce sont
les les les collectivité ce qu' en aura
dans toute l'île-de- France en fait et
on a souhaité avec le préfet de région
île-de-fance puisque une partie de ces
club d'animation sont sont financés donc
avec le préfet de la région de France on
a souhaité en limiter le nombre quand
même he de manière à ne pas
démultiplier le la protection moins pour
les forces de l'ordre finalement que
pour les polices municipales et pour
pour la sécurité privée et puis le
parcours de la flamme oui alors on y
travaille hein c'est un si pour ce qui
est de la zone de Paris
principalement la flamme arrive le 14 et
revient à Paris pour le le le 26 2526 en
fait hein donc on a un cheminement qui
est encadré avec une bulle mais c'est
quelque chose qui est assez mouvant et
les embarras de circulation seront quand
même assez limités he c'est un petit
c'est un peu comme une petite course
automobile mais tout ça on y travaille
alors la concertation he pour répondre
clairement à votre question la
concertation elle porte sur le tout hein
elle porte sur elle porte sur le tout
c'est-à-dire les conditions d'accès et
les périmètres hein évidemment moi j'ai
des élus qui m'ont déjà évoqué la
possibilité d'étendre le périmètre rouge
légèrement à la marge parce qu'il
considèrent que à tel endroit la
circulation serait dangereuse voilà donc
ou le périmètre bleu pour avoir une
déviation un peu plus en amont donc on a
déjà on va regarder ça et cette
concertation elle porte bien sur le
périmètre et les conditions d'accès je
suis sûr que les les maires
d'arrondissement Parisiens auront aussi
forcément de nombreuses remarques sur
les périmètres et donc la discussion
portera aussi sur ces périmètres sur le
justificatif donc la question clé le
justificatif moi j'ai cité le QR code il
y a deux types de de justificatifs hein
soit euh la personne donc qui veut
bénéficier d'une dérogation encore une
fois pour rentrer dans une zone rouge
j'insiste parce qu'hier j'ai lu beaucoup
de choses qui étaient complètement
fausse on disait que pour circuler à
pied dans Paris il fallait un QR code
enfin c'est c'est complètement faux on
parle que des zones de circulation
routière autour des sites qui sont très
limitées et donc pour avoir une
dérogation pour bénéficier de la
dérogation faut remplir les conditions
il faut que les forces de l'ordre
puissent le contrôler facilement à
l'entrée sinon c'est absolument pas
gérable ça devient ingérable bon euh
encore une fois l'alternative serait de
fermer la circulation en routière et ce
n'est pas ce que nous souhaitons donc il
y a deux possibilités soit il y a une
donc évidemment on remplit les
conditions sur la plateforme on va
fournir un certain nombre de
justificatifs j'habite à tel endroit euh
donc on le justifie et je m'appelle
l'tel évidemment et donc et donc il y a
un justificatif qui sera émis donc le ou
ou ou un QR code c'est voilà le sujet il
est là-dessus le débat portera là-dessus
comment micro micro micro et excusez-moi
monsieur le Préfet mais qui va vérifier
sur la plateforme les justificatifs pour
donner l'autorisation c'est nous c'est
la police nationale c'est c'est la
décision d'accès est une décision
souveraine qui ne peut pas être déléguée
hein ce sera forcément les force de
sécurité publique ou enfin c'est du
régalien hein dans tout toute dans
toute le droit français bâti d'une telle
façon qu'il y a un certain nombre de
missions qu'on peut déléguer toutes
celles qui sont détachables des missions
de souveraineté on peut les déléguer
c'està direire que le recueil des
documents et cetera ça c'est une chose
mais le le le contrôle et la décision
d'accès ne relève que de l'autorité
publique et qui contrôlera évidemment
l'autorité publique à l'entrée de la
zone de circulation donc soit avec un
justificatif soit avec un QR code on
verra ce qui est le plus pratique sa le
ccode ça va beaucoup plus vite hein donc
voilà il faut aussi penser à la fluidité
à la fluidité des
passages et et faire en sorte que on on
cause le moin de désagrément à la fois
pour les forces de l'ordre qui vont
avoir des contrôles mais surtout surtout
pour les riverins par exemple qui
voudront rejoindre leur parking en zone
rouge aux abords immédiats des
périmètres tout en évitant
fr tout en évitant les fraudes aussi
tout en évitant les fruds
euh voilà sur le sur le
donc sur la communication d'hier
effectivement elle nous a ramené vous
avez raison madame la sénatrice au
principe de de la réalité hein ça c'est
sûr bon maintenant il y avait il y avait
deux options je vous cache pas qu'il y
avait deux options il y avait une option
qui consistait à dire on va aller
rencontrer les grands acteurs avec nos
documents nos cartes les maires
d'arrondissement les grands
professionnels du secteur moi j'ai
rencontré il y a 2 jours l'ensemble des
acteurs du bâtiment et des travaux
publics d'île-de-fance quand même on
commence déjà expliquer les choses bon
ben il y avait la solution de consulter
sans rendre publi nos cartes bon vous
connaissez la vraie vie bien mieux que
moi les cartes se seraient retrouvé dans
la presse tout de suite et sans les
explications qui vont avec bon je crois
que ça aurait été catastrophique donc on
a plutôt choisi de de en lien avec
l'ensemble des élus concernés évidemment
avec le la décision a été prise par le
ministre de l'intérieur on on l'a évoqué
on a choisi plutôt que d'avoir à subir
des cartes qui ce qui aurait fuité ici
ou là parce qu'on s'était engagé dans
une démarche de concertation et que donc
forcément la concertation l'a fait en
donnant des cartes hein on peut pas le
laffire comme ça sur sur feuille blanche
ou simplement avec des explications
orales et donc on a
préféré dire qu'on lançait le processus
de concertation et rendre publique la
base de cette concertation avec les
explications qui vont avec de manière à
éviter qu'on se retrouve avec des des
des des avec une une rentrée dans le
monde de la réalité encore plus brutale
que ce que vous disiez un de la ganterie
donc voilà donc donc c'est c'est pour
cela que nous avons fait cela euh est-ce
qu'il y aura une nouvelle saisine de
l'acnil moi je ne sais pas nous on va
consulter l'acnil on va la consulter
évidemment he sur ce dispositif
juridique que Don dont dont don dont je
vais le dont je viens de parler
évidemment on va vous appuyz sur la loil
micro non non non on s'appuiera pas sur
la loisilte moi je m'appoie sur l'arrêté
de 2011 hein euh donc voilà je je je je
vais définir une zone de sécurité mais
tout ça je le verrai avec avec laacine
hein pour alors là le sujet dont on
parle l'il c'est vraiment pour la
cérémonie d'ouverturein vraiment he
parce que pour les autres sites il y a
pas de il y a pas de sujet et
là le périmètre de la cérémonie
d'ouverture c'est évidemment la loi silt
mais c'est aussi une zone de sécurité
c'est aussi une zone de sécurité où on
peut décider de restreindre l'accès
et que ce que nous autorise à faire
l'arrêté de 2011 c'est à traiter c'est à
instaurer un système de traitement de
données au fin afin de contrôler une
zone de sécurité au plus près d'un grand
événement c'est ça que nous autorise cet
arrêté donc évidemment j'en discuterai
avec l'acnil sur les algorithmes
évidemment donc ce sera l'objet d'un
autre débat mais nous y travaillons pour
les jeux he dans le cadre de la nouvelle
loi alors en lien très étroit avec le
ministère puisque c'est le ministère qui
passe le marché donc nous y travaillons
nous avons plusieurs cas d'usage ça je
pourrais vous en parler le moment venu
sans difficulté sur les sur le la presse
a fait état effectivement d'un logiciel
de reconnaissance faciale d'une société
hein donc moi je donc le ministre a
saisi là là-dessus là nous nous
n'utilisons pas ce logiciel de cette
sociétélà après la recofaciale elle est
elle est permise dans le cadre donc de
en judiciaire he en procédure judiciaire
dans un cadre bien bien précis euh mais
qui elle ne se fait pas avec des
logiciels de à ma connaissance de de
boîte privée hein mais tout ça comme l'a
annoncé le ministre nous aurons il y a
une enquête le ministre a demandé une
enquête des inspections générales euh
donc voilà moi je je l'utilisez pas nous
n'utilisons pas le logiciel actuellement
nous n'utilisons pas ce logiciel de la
société qui a été cité et euh c'est la
question précise qui nous a été posée à
l'époque et c'est ce qui est sorti dans
la presse euh sur la sécurité privée
voilà je moi je n'ai pas de raison
d'être inquiet sur ce sujet à à ce
moment précis hein il y a encore des
appels d'offre il y a encore des lots
qui n'ont pas été euh qui n'ont pas été
euh dépouillé euh enfin oui euh pour pas
pas par euh par le cojot euh donc voilà
donc euh il y a pas de raison de penser
que la sécurité privée sera pas au
rendez-vous euh en tout cas moi je
travaille surtout sur les plans des
force de sécurité intérieure c'est déjà
un vaste travail euh puisque nous allons
avoir en moyenne 30000 fonctionnaires de
ces militaires euh de la gendarmerie
voire des des armées euh sur Paris et
l'Île-de-France 30000 hein sur la zone
et même parfois un pic à 45000 notamment
euh notamment pour euh pour la cérémonie
d'ouverture merci merci Monsieur le
Préfet madame de La Gonterie avec un
micro votre réponse me perplexifie ça
veut dire que vous n'avz pas de
compétenence sur la sur la question de
sécurité
privée c'est non non c'est
l'organisateur qui non mais donc qui
coordonne l'ensemble des dispositifs de
sécurité si c'était pas vous non mais
moi je je d'abord moi je coordonne tous
les forces de sécurité intérieure sur
l'ensemble de la région il-de-fance en
lien évidemment étroit avec les préfets
de département ça c'est le prier prier
point ensuite la sécurité privée elle va
être essentiellement engagée par
l'organisateur par le COJO pour ses
propres dispositif de sécurité
c'est-à-dire que le COJO va devoir gérer
ses sites va devoir gérer oui si bien
sûr on est en coordination mais c'est on
se coordonne évidemment en
opérationnel mais mais je ne suis pas je
n'ai pas autorité sur ces personnes mais
oui on se coordonne c'estàdire que ils
vont être chargés de sécuriser les sites
olympiques ils vont être chargés de
sécuriser leur flotte ils vont être
chargés de sécuriser
les accès au Keba pour la cérémonie
d'ouverture puisque c'est un périmètre
COJO mais nous nous n'avons pas autorité
évidemment sur eux madame canailler oui
merci monsieur le Président j'ai une
dernière petite question Monsieur le
Préfet dans la loi sur la sécurisation
des Jeux Olympiques nous avons conféré
les pouvoirs de préfet de police sur
l'ensemble des cinq départements durant
les Jeux olympiques mais qui a compté du
1er juillet 2024 or on voit bien qu'il y
a un énorme travail de préparation
aujourd'hui voit que dans les annonces
qui ont été faites hier trois
départements sont concernés de deux
autres communiqueront plus tard est-ce
que pour vous il n'y a pas de difficulté
aujourd'hui n'ayant pas encore ces
prérogatives complètes d'harmoniser de
coordonner ce travail préparatoire non
parce que je je suis préfet de zone donc
j'ai déjà un pouvoir de coordination et
puis ça se passe en bonne intelligence
donc vous voyez par exemple sur ces
périmètres on sera tous mis d'accord sur
le fait qu'on appliquerait les mêmes
règles pour avoir une une uniformisation
de de la gestion des périmètres sur
l'ensemble de la région non ça pose pas
de problème le plus important c'est que
les compétences qui me sont donné sont
surtout des compétences de direction
aussi des forces de police
opérationnelles euh ça a été un souhait
du gouvernement et surtout du CIO
d'avoir un interlocuteur unique sur une
zone où 80 % des jeux ou 85 % des jeux
26 sites vont se dérouler d'avoir un
interlocuteur unique donc à partir du du
du 1er juillet effectivement euh je
deviens compétent mais et je et je vais
avoir un certain nombre de police
spéciale hein don donc vous savez quand
il va falloir déroger pour savoir si on
peut survoler un site olympique à dans
dans l'ensemble dans dans en tout point
de la région c'est moi qui serai
compétent mais ça la la question va se
poser pendant les Jeux ça ça ça
n'empêche pas de les préparer tous
ensemble sans aucune difficulté ça ne
pose pas de de problème par contre au
moment où les jeux vont débuter d'où ces
dates du 1er juillet au 15 septembre là
effectivement il sera sans doute plus
utile de d'exercer effectivement ses
compétences dont une grande partie
seront délégués en réalité hein donc
dans une grande partie seront délégués
mais en cas de crise en cas de coup dur
il faut toujours qu'il y ait qu'une
personne qui prenne les commandes merci
Monsieur le Préfet j'ai deux demandes de
parole mais j'avais une petite question
à tiroir avant à vous poser est-ce que
vous avez une estimation du nombre de
résidents et donc de véhicules qui sont
dans les zones que vous avez délimité
euh déjà à priori donc de personnes
concernées premier tiroir comment seront
prévenus les touristes parce qu'il y a
pas mal d'hôtels dans les zones qui sont
délimitées et même question pour les
touristes qui prendrai des locations
Airbnb comment seront-ils prévenus pour
s'enregistrer sur la
plateforme et après je passe la parole à
mes
collègues la première question pardon
l'estimation de oui ah oui l'estimation
alors l'estimation je ser plus pr si euh
la prochaine les véhicule je ne l'ai pas
euh mais les résidents dans la les
résidents dans la zone alors les
résidents dans les zone rouge à Paris je
crois de mémoire que c'est 20000
personnes euh c'est 20000 personnes donc
il ont pas tous des véhicules qui ont
pas tous vocation bon mais tout ça je
vérifierai avec la Ville de Paris et les
établissements publics les
établissements pardon commerciaux les
bars resto je crois de mémoire que c'est
700 dont un/ers de restaurant mais tout
ça je vais vous le préciser nous l'avons
c'est plutôt la V de Paris he qui a
connaissance de ça mais on n'est pas non
plus sur des nombres on n'est pas sur
des nombres illimités de personnes euh
pour les pour les touristes les
personnes qui réserveront des hôtels
d'où l'intérêt de d'arrêter
définitivement les règles fin janvier
hein parce que ce sont les propriétaires
d'hôtel ceux qui louont leur appartement
qui devront faire connaître au
locataires ou aux clients des hôtels ces
règles-là hein les modalités
d'inscription dont on va discuter avec
les professionnels aussi hein il y a
plusieurs possibilités hein pour les
hôtels soit c'est l'hôtel qui enregistre
les qui signale les clients qui vont
venir ce qui nous semble être la
meilleure formule mais on en discutera
évidemment avec l'UMI avec la
profession soit soit évidemment ce sont
les les les touristes les clients qui
s'enregistrent mais ça peut être plus
compliqué pour eux hein ça peut plus
être compliqué pour eux d'autant que les
hôteliers souvent disposent de ces
informations voilà mais tout ça ça sera
ouvert évidemment à la à la concertation
discutera avec les professionnels pour
les plateformes de location c'est par un
accord avec les plateformes env avec
tout ça tout ça tout ça on y réfléchit
c'est sûr que nous on sera guidé à la
fois par des considérations on aura le
la même philosophie c'est-à-dire une
approche qui veut qu'on ne va pas on va
on va on va laisser la vie économique se
dérouler normalement mais en ayant des
modalités enfin de de de contrôle et de
vérification qui seront quand même qui
nous permettront quand même de savoir
qui
euh parce que là la question ce dont on
parle c'est que sur la cérémonie
d'ouverture c'est tout hein
on mais pour la cérémonie d'ouverture le
sujet see et vous comprz qu'il faut
quand même qu' qu'on soit un pe au
courant de qui réside dans les
appartements les chambres
d'hôtel les endroits où on a un visuel
sur la scène c'est un enjeu de sécurité
majeur monsieur André
richchard merci Président Monsieur le
Préfet de Police moi je suis sénateur du
Barin don vous savez naturellement que
le chef-lieu est Strasbourg ce
Strasbourg qui reçoit chaque année le
marché de
Noël je je parle sous le couvert d'un
ancien adjoint qui connaît bien c'est
c'est entre 1 et 2 millions de visiteurs
sur une période de 3 4
semaines ça se passe naturellement dans
différents points de Strasbourg
donc ce que vous appelez le cas échéant
sur les Jeux Olympiques des sites voilà
chacun ayant naturellement ses propres
contraintes ses propres difficultés et
cetera et je voudrais vous poser des
questions précisément contte tenu de
l'expérience
que je peux avoir maintenant depuis
quelques années soit dit en passant ça
n'a pas enêcher l'attentat que vous
connaissez tous qui montre
que rien n'est jamais
parfait les questions sont dans l'ordre
les suivantes on a bien compris enfin
j'ai bien compris moi vous avait
largement insisté là-dessus que les
restrictions porteraient essentiellement
ou enfin quasiment uniquement sur la
circulation routière
euh pas pas pas les pas les piétons pas
pas les pas les
cyclistes cuid le cas échiant des deux
roues motorisées c'est une première
question mais celle-ci est incidente la
deuxème question est-ce que porte sur
les créneaux horair de
de d'interdiction enfin de de limit non
d'interdiction pour le coup de de de
circulation pourquoi je vous dis ça
parce
que dans la ville dont je viens de vous
parler les les le marché de Noël
naturellement dure le jour la nuit et
cetera enfin du moins les les les outils
les cabanes sont là et ce en tout ce que
vous vous voyez traditionnellement dans
un marché de Noël cert ils sont fermés à
une certaine heure mais il y a encore
naturellement beaucoup de personnes qui
se déplacent à cette occasion là parce
que c'est une occasion de faire la fête
donc là des créneaux sont créneaux
horaires sont prévus on ouvre
officiellement à telle heure on ferme à
telle heure
et au-delà de cette heure-là les
voitures peuvent accéder bien notamment
pour permettre au au Riverin de de de
garer leur voiture chez eux et cetera et
cetera donc est-il prévu quelque chose
comme cela et le cas échéant est-ce que
vous pouvez nous donner des informations
sur ces horaires si tant est que il soit
déjà déjà fixé immédiatement derrière se
pose la question du stationnement bien à
Strasbourg on va jusqu'à excusez-moi de
prendre cette exemple mais ça ça ça ça
vous donne naturellement quelques pistes
de réflexion si si vous deviez en
manquer Monsieur le Préfet
euh le stationnement est strictement
interdit du du du actuellement de tête
je crois que tu du commencer le le 22 ou
le 23 novembre jusqu'au 24 décembre à mi
pas de stationnement nulle part bien
ceci pour des raisons qu'on peut bien
comprendre bien donc est-ce qu'il est
prévu quelque chose comme ça j'ai bien
compris qu'à priori le risque porte
essentiellement sur la cérémonie
d'ouverture mais je je je me pose quand
même la question de savoir si dans
d'autres sites autour de autour de
notamment les les les stades concernés
et cetera est-ce que vraiment on peut
se limiter simplement à un périmètre
hors entre guillemets population hors
résident vous vous semblez dire que oui
mais merci de me le confirmer je
voudrais Infiné vous dire que
naturellement cette ces restrictions
sont éminemment impopulaires vous vous
en doutez bien éminemment impopulaires à
telle enseigne que au fil des années ça
fait maintenant des années qu'on a ce
genre de chos le le marché de Strasbourg
prenant une ampleur absolument terrible
vous avez compris euh entre 1 et 2
millions voire 2 millions euh la
population est excédée donc elle est
excédée par quoi elle est excédée par
les les checkpoint d'entrée et sortie
pour ceux qui bénéficient de dérogation
parce que c'est bien comme ça qu'il les
appelle les checkpoint et et ils sont
excédés par la la la la lenteur la
longueur de ces au début c'était
absolument épouvantable donc moi je
milite naturellement même si ça plaît
pas à d'autres pour une plateforme
d'inscription préalable ça se fait à
Strasbour jour mais malheureusement ça
suffit pas vraiment ça ne suffit pas des
gens qui ont leur badge et ils ont leur
badge ont quelque chose dans la voiture
parce que naturellement même SS on le
bat j'en ouvre quand même le coffre
clairement et il faut le faire enfin
c'est c'est c'est évident donc ça prend
du temps les gens sont excédés les les
les les artisans qui veulent accéder au
centre sont excédés de la même façon
naturellement la moitié d'entre eux ont
oublié de faire la demande sur la
plateforme hein je parle de ceux qui qui
ne sont pas de Strasbourg pas les
riverins mais enfin c'est c'est c'est je
suis juste obligé de vous dire que c'est
à l'heure actuelle je actuellement ça a
démarré donc je peux vous en parler
j'entends déjà ce que disent les gens
bien et donc la conclusion de tout ça
c'est et je termine la conclusion de
tout ça ça a été de dire et de toute
façon on n pas empêché l'attentat bien
bah ça vaut pas la peine de continuer
comme ça et d'autant plus allez je
caricature à peine mais je l'entends
tous les jours pour çais V dire sauf
quand je suis à Paris bien sûr he bien
euh on me dit bah maintenant on a
restreint les créneaux maintenant c'est
11h du matin 20h je crois c'est quelque
chose comme ça bon à quoi ça sert
puisque de nous embêter comme ça les
gens qui veulent commettre quelque chose
ils viennent avant 11h ils vont poser
leur bombes avant ils vont et cetera et
cetera donc ça sert à rien à telle
enceinene que maintenant les je vais
vous dire moi je suis passé
à dimanche matin à 11h Mo le cas bon
avec un cabat je vou j'ai voulu ouvrir
le cabat les types étaient là ils ont
dit non non c'est pas encore l'heure
vous pouvez passer on garde pas le cabat
donc je voilà je voudrais simplement
attirer votre attention sur le côté mais
vous le savez bien sur le côté vraiment
sensible de de ce type de démarche et la
nécessité vraiment de de de
allez d'avoir un maximum de bon sens
pour éviter à la fois il faut trouver le
bon équilibre pour éviter à la fois
excusez-moi d'utiliser ce terme
d'emmerder les Français euh et d'un
autre côté de naturellement de sécuriser
au maximum l'événement qui va se passer
excusez-moi d'avoir été long mais et je
suis sûr que vous l'avez déjà fait si
vous n'avez pas déjà pris contact
avec Madame la préfèette de de de du
Grand Est et du Barin il faut le faire
parce que c'est les enseignements que
nous avons tiré de tout ce qui s'est
passé à Strasbourg depuis des dizaines
d'années pour un événement de grande
ampleur hein je répète he bien parler de
20000 personnes concernées à Strasbourg
c'est beaucoup plus que ça beaucoup plus
que ça et
et très franchement je voudrais pas
gérer à votre place
monsieur beats merci beaucoup Président
Monsieur le Préfet merci euh de venir à
à à nous je pense que les explications
que vous a apporté sont parfaitement
claires et précises et et j'avoue que
moi personnellement ne pas avoir bien
compris les mois suscités par vos
déclarations par la conférence de presse
que vous avez donné au aux Parisiens
alors parispierre de la contr m'apporte
un élément d'explication effectivement
on rentre dans le principe de réalité
pour pour un certain nombre de de
personnes évidemment euh le fait d'avoir
été candidate à l'organisation des Jeux
Olympiques pour la France et pour la
ville de Paris emporte des conséquences
qui vont être énormes euh sur la vie
quotidienne euh des des des Parisiens
des Franciliens pendant cette pendant
cette période-là et euh André reichchard
parlait à juste titre du du marché de
Strasbourg c'est vrai que j'étais
adjoint chargé de la sécurité à
Strasbourg entre 2008 et 2014 donc
autant dire que même sur un événement
qui a plus de 4 siècles d'exist cendré
et ben le point d'équilibre n'a toujours
pas été trouvé et effectivement tous les
ans il y a des des ajustements des
mesures et on a conscience du caractère
parfaitement imparfait de chaque
dispositif de de sécurité mais même
effectivement un événement pour lequel
les Strasbourg rougeois sont préparés
tous les ans ils savent ce qui va se
passer c'est vrai que c'est c'est c'est
très compliqué pour les les habitants le
supporter mais je une fois qu'on a dit
ça je vois pas bien euh ce que l'on peut
faire concrètement en tout cas moi j'ai
pas bien compris les mois
euh suscités et surtout cette injonction
en fait à l'autorité administrative on
va dire d'immédiatement enfin de ce
soupçon d'irrégularité juridique de de
son action moi je voilà je trouve ça un
petit peu déplacé on sait qu'on va
rentrer dans des mois qui sont très
difficiles et je trouve qu'il est pas
possible qu'il a des injonctions de
cette nature- làà en direction de
l'autorité administratif chaque fois que
le dispositif de sécurité est précisé
parce que sinon on ne s'en sortira pas
collectivement ça c'était le le le
premier point que je souhaitais aborder
pour pour dire ensuite que André
richchard parlait du marché de Noël moi
en tant qu'adjoint à la sécurité à
Strasbourg j'ai surtout le souvenir du
sommet de l'OTAN en 2009 évidemment qui
était un événement de de de grande
ampleur
euh où là aussi les mesures restrictives
avaient été extrêmement fortes il était
pas possible qu'il en soit autrement
comme ça a été le cas pour le le G7 à à
à Biaritz mais moi la la question que je
je souhaitais poser plus précise et vous
y répondrez si si vous pouvez si vous
voulez euh c'est sur la question
effectivement de cette dérogation à la
circulation euh automobile est-ce que le
critère d'attribution de la dérogation
sera exclusivement lié à la nécessité
justifiée de pouvoir se déplacer dans le
périmètre ou est-ce qu'il y aura un
criblage évidemment des personnes et qui
font la qui font la demande euh parce
que je crois que c'est c'est ça la la
vraie question euh de de sécurité
aujourd'hui autant vous dire je sais pas
ce qui est juridiquement possible ou pas
mais c'est évident que lorsqu'on a
autant de piétons qui circulent aux
abords des sites des sites olympiques et
parallympique de faire rentrer des
véhicules c'est un c'est évidemment un
danger euh pour la la sécurité de de la
population et et donc voilà je voilà
c'est une demande de précision si vous
pouvez l'apporter euh que que je
souhaiterais avoir en tout cas moi dans
le bon sens qu'invoquit André rachart me
pousserait plutôt évidemment à être
favorable à ce criblage s'il était
possible qu'on s'entende bien je n
verrai pas du tout une menace pour les
les libertés mais bien au contraire une
sécurisation pour nos concitoyens même
si on sait qu'elle sera jamais parfaite
mais avec des des cartes qui sont et
c'est le principe de la la transparence
dont vous faites preuve et vous avez de
toute façon pas le choix sur le fond
faut bien apporter les éléments mais
vous indiquez des mois à l'avance quel
va être le dispositif les périmètres et
donner ainsi aussi la carte à à
d'éventuels auteurs d'actes d'actes
malfaisant donc par rapport à à à ça cet
équilibre qu'il faut réussir à à trouver
qui qui est pas qui est pas évident
voilà est-ce que il y a moyen de
s'assurer que ces autorisations de
circulation dans le périmètrre soit bien
donné à des personnes qui ne sont pas
déjà connu des services mais on sait
bien que les serv ne connaissent de
toute façon pas tout merci Monsieur bit
madame Nara
cigin merci eu moi je voudrais déjà
commencer par dire parce que même si
Mariepierre a raison de rappeler il y a
un principe de réalité qui fait que il y
a des inquiétudes qui qui montrent que
je suis sénatrice de la sainte sie et et
si même si ça s'appelle les Jeux
olympiques de Paris une grande partie
d'entre eux se dérouleront en sainte sie
et dans ce département nous sommes très
heureux d'accueillir beaucoup
d'événements parce que ça va ça va
apporter ça apporte déjà évidemment de
nouvelles infrastructures et puis et
puis il y aura un héritage qu'on espèera
bénéfique pour le département sur le
long terme et puis ça sera aussi quand
même un moment de fête parce
qu'aujourd'hui les gens râent mais quand
on va commencer à quand on aura on sera
dans le moment de de de la cérémonie je
pense que il y a une atmosphère générale
qui fait que
aussi la le le point de vue changera y
compris pour les habitants et et surtout
dans la mesure où
vous jouez pleinement votre rôle qui est
de de rendre les choses euh de de
sécuriser de de de d'apporter de la
tranquillité d'esprit à chacun sans
entraver justement le bon déroulement
des opérations bien au contraire et on
sait que même s il y a eu effectivement
des épisodes dramatiques avec avec la
coupe la la la finale de la de la
Champions League il y a aussi eu
beaucoup d'événements qu'on s'est très
bien organisé très réussis et et ser
estce que dans les dernières années
l'Euro 2016 ou ou encore plus récemment
la Coupe du monde de
rugby donc ma question est est est
donc et quand même plus sur cette
question des des périmètres sur la scène
saint on a quand même une inquiétude
dans la la manière dont les choses se
mettent en place qui est que il y a
énormément
d'hébergements d'urgence en sain saint
et notamment pour certains très près des
sites olympiques et que même si les
périmètres vont filtrer essentiellement
la la circulation automobile le fait
qu'il a une présence de police
extrêmement forte peut décourager
beaucoup de ces personnes en situation
de précarité d'aller vers ses
hébergements d'urgence et donc de se
retrouver
euh dans la rue dans voilà donc sans
sans la possibilité ou ou en craignant
de passer les barrages de police pour
aller dans les endroits où ils seront
accueillis et où ils pourront passer la
nuit et donc je voulais savoir comment
est-ce que vous comptez aussi prendre en
compte cette questionl
Monsieur le Préfet et
après donc sur toutes les questions qui
m'ont été posées d'abord monsieur le
sénateur du du du barrain sur les deou
motorisées elles seront traité elles
seront traité comme les véhicules hein
donc les deou
motorisé ne seront interdites dans les
périmètres rouges de circulation
uniquement il faudra obtenir une
dérogation les créneau horaires sont
prévus effectivement on active ces
périmètres
que enfin 2h30 avant le début des
compétitions et on on les on les
désactive 1 heure après la fin des
compétitions voilà mais tout ça on va
évidemment le c'est ce qui est prévu on
va en discuter mais là ce sont plutôt
dans la cadre de la concertation là
c'est calé sur les heures de compétition
moi je peux pas les changer j'ai pas ce
pouvoir donc ça on sera ce sont les
horaires qui je pense sonont sans doute
définitivement retenu il y a pas de
raison qu'on bouge les choses c'est pas
comme la le le le la cartographie des
des des périmètrre ou les conditions
desendroits euh alors évidemment le
village olympique en sa Sany lui c'est
H24 voilà donc il y a quand même des
sites qui vont être où la cérémonie
d'ouverture ce sera plusieurs jours
avant et ce sera nonstop évidemment mais
ça ce sont plus des exceptions mais qui
seront effectivement contraignantes hein
le le périmètre rouge le le j'étais hier
avec le maire de Saint-Denis qui me
disait que dans le périmètre rouge sur
sa commune c'est quelques milliers de
personne quand même hein donc voilà euh
sur les le stationnement dans cette zone
rouge
ce sont des choses qu'on va réglementer
par la suite hein là aujourd'hui pour le
coup je ne sais pas répondre à cette
question mais effectivement on le
prévoit toujours c'est dans cette zone
de restriction d'interdiction de
circulation il peut y avoir des mesures
de stationnement qui sont prises en plus
pour faciliter les flux de piéthon comme
on fait lors des manifestations on
demande évidemment ce qu' n'estit pas de
voiture dans l'avenue ça on y a pas
encore travaillé c'est beaucoup trop tôt
he c'est beaucoup trop tôt et c'est
c'est aussi pour cela qu'on de qu'on
autorise les riverins à rentrer dans ces
périmètres en véhicule uniquement
lorsqu'ils ont des parking privé parce
que si on les autorisait à stationner
sur la voie publique il pourrait
stationner sur des endroits que nous on
souhaite voir libre dans ce périmètre
qui est encore fois un périmètre où les
piétons vont circuler notamment les
spectateurs des des jeux et sur le ce
que vous disiez effectivement sur la
gestion desck checkpoint comme vous
dites à à
Strasbourg c'est c'est tout le débat
qu'on a sur la plateforme hein c'est le
bon sens versus emmerder les gens quoi
comme je reprends votre expression je me
permets mais voilà moi j'ai le sentiment
qu'une plateforme c'est moins ennuyer
les gens parce que on a une fois une
fois pour toutes d'abord on s'enregistre
en ligne c'est beaucoup plus rapide et
puis pour un Riverin il a une fois pour
toute son autorisation voilà j'ai j'ai
le sentiment que le bon sens plaide
plutôt vers la mise en place d'une
plateforme mais vous avez raison il faut
pas il faut que ce soit fluide il faut
pas que les gens attendent sinon ça sera
très pénible pour les fonctionnaires de
police et encore plus pour les personnes
qui seront autorisées à y rentrer et qui
devront faire faire la queue euh le
l'ouverture des coffres de véhicules
c'est parce que les véhicules à
Strasbourg rentrent dans le périmètre de
protection hein donc le périmètre rouge
n'est pas un périmètre de protection
sens lo silt c'est pas donc je réponds
je réponds doublement aux questions il y
a pas forcément de fouille du véhicule
hein et il y a pas de criblage et il y a
pas de criblage évidemment on n'est pas
sur une zone on n'est pas sur une zone
couverte par le décret grand événement
en en tout cas à ce stade et je ne le
demande pas hein donc on n'est pas on
n'est pas il y a pas de criblage il y a
pas de fouille forcément de véhicule
après sur réquisition du procureur parce
qu'on a connaissance d'une menace
évidemment on pourra nous demander un
78 du code de procédure pénale 2 parce
qu'on a une menace connaissance d'une
menace précise on pourra faire ouvrir
les coffres mais mais il faudrait qu'il
y ait une menace et qu'on le justifie
que ça peut être sur acquisition du
procureur ça n'est pas que ça ne sera
pas un silt hein je pense que la
différence avec le marché de Strasbourg
elle se situe à ce niveau-là et donc je
réponds en même temps à votre question
monsieur le sénateur non il y a pas il y
aura pas de cribage juridiquement ça
n'est pas possible et je je ne pense pas
qu'on puisse inclure les périmètres de
circulation dans le décret grand
événement pourquoi parce que nous
n'allons contrôler de toute façon que
les véhicules qui rentrent c'estàd
vérifier qu'ils peuvent passer mais les
piétons les vélos rentreront librement
donc vous voyez ce serait une mesure qui
serait qui serait pas forcément
pertinente parce que les les les piétons
eux passeraient sans sans contrôle
excuse-moi je permet de préciser la
question c'était par rapport à au
possible utilisation de de voiturees en
terme comme arme par destination comme
voiture bélier et donc de s'assurer que
la la la personne effectivement ne soit
pas déjà connue voilà c'est tout ce que
je veux d'accord non non je je comprends
bien le sens mais voilà juridiquement ça
n'est pas possible et vous pensez que ça
serait utile je je pour pouvoir le faire
il faudrait le le le il faudrait que il
faudrait que on le décret grand
événement inclut mes périmètres de mes
zones de sécurité mes périmètres mais
avec le décret grand événement comme
vous le savez vous ne pouvez pas cribler
tout le monde hein donc ce
sontectur
donc on peut pas cribeler tout le monde
il y a des conditions très strictes donc
je ne suis même pas sûr que ce soit
utile voilà mais bon voilà je je à ce
stade je ne pense pas que ce soit
possible juridiquement et sur la
dernière question sur le madame sur le
effectivement ça typiquement ce sont des
questions qu'il faudra avir dans le
cadre de la concertation il sera
important que chaque maire indique les
établissements de ce genre qui sont
situés dans le périmètre rouge et qu'on
prévoit des des dispositions approprié
mais évidemment
que ce que ces personnes se rendent à
pied dans ces centres donc il y a y a il
y a aucune raison que elles en soi
empêché mais tout ça c'est des ce sont
typiquement dans le cadre de la
consultation avec chaque élu CE sont
c'est à eux de de signaler aussi ce type
d'établissement comment on va le gérer
et comment les choses vont se passer
pour que ce soit pour je reprends le
propos de Monsieur le Sénateur pour
qu'on soit dans le plus dans on reste
dans le bon sens c'est ça le bon sens et
moi j'ai un autre impératif et je vous
remercie monsieur le le sénateur de
l'avoir de l'avoir souligné c'est aussi
l'impératif de sécurité hein
et voilà et merci monsieurateur pour
monsieur le sénateur pour vos propos
mais je je quand bien même cette
audition était vraiment programmée par
ailleurs évidemment si j'avais été
invité convoqué ou je ne sais que quoi
pour ne parler que de ce qui s'est passé
hier je serais quand même venu he n'ayez
crainte dernière intervenant madame
Floren merci monsieur le Président merci
Monsieur le Préfet je rejoins ce qu'a
dit mon collègue bits sur les mois qui a
pu susciter
vos vos propos hier et vous redire que
moi en tant que franilienne altosekan je
plutôt on est plutôt attentif et pour la
population attentif aussi à la sécurité
qui sera apportée poures pour ces
événements et sur les lieux justement
concernés moi je vous remercie également
pour la concertation mise en place parce
que je pense que c'est une bonne chose
que de l'anticiper et évidemment vous
l'avez compris il faudra de la pédagogie
mais euh s'il y a de la concertation et
de l'association aussi des acteurs
locaux je pense qu'on on pourra
travailler avec les élus locaux en ce
sens moi j'avais une une question liée
enfin tout simplement parce que c'est
pas la quand même la première fois que
des Jeux Olympiques se se déroulent dans
une capitale euh d'un d'un grand pays et
je voulais savoir justement quel
leçon et si vous les aviez tiré et si
vous inspiriez de ce qui a pu être fait
notamment et des difficultés d'ailleurs
quand on reprend l'histoire en terme de
sécurité rencontré au préalable pas
durant les compétitions mais avant à
Londres en 2012 parce que on sait très
bien qu'en terme de sécurité ça a pas
été simple sur Londres et éventuellement
à Rio après en tout cas est-ce qu'à
chaque fois il y a y a une continuité
entre en tout cas une analyse j'imagine
quand même sur sur l'expérience et sur
l'apprentissage même si les conditions
sont pas tout à fait les mêmes notamment
pour la cérémonie d'ouverture merci
Monsieur richchard pour 10 secondes
voilà j'avais oublié de vous poser une
question Monsieur le Préfet de police si
on passe si on passe par une plateforme
comme
proposé
avez-vous une idée de la la durée de
stockage des données dans cette
plateforme euh je je je sais pas du tout
comment ça se passe à Strasbourg pour
revenir à cela je suis pas persuadé que
soit la police nationaleilleurs qui
Créel je sais pas bien donc voilà et et
dernière et ultime intervenant madame de
La Gonterie oui c'est pas une question
c'est c'est un petit peu un mot de
conclusion parce que vous avez compris
que moi aussi je j'avais un peu été
surprise par les mois provoqués même si
je trouve toujours positif que les
sénateurs se préoccupent des libertés
publiques euh c'est vraiment quelque
chose d'important mais je c'est du
premier degré ce que je dis et que quand
même on peut saluer le fait que on est à
239 jours non j'imagine que dans votre
bureau vous avez
un donc je crois qu'on est à 239 jours
et donc avoir aussi en amont toutes ces
informations et cetera c'est quelque
chose de formidable donc il faut voir
les choses de manière un peu
positive Monsieur le
Préfet avec 239
cases
Monsieur le Préfet alors et lui seul
merci madame de la Conterie pour vos
propos euh je je crois avant de répondre
aux questions mais il est il est il est
logique
que on s'attend au fur à mesure qu'on va
dérouler nos plans de sécurité
évidemment on s'attend ce qu'on ait
beaucoup de questions et et et on s'y
prépare et en tout cas moi je vous redis
que je suis à la disposition de la
mission hein pour venir exposer à
échéance régulière la façon dont on on
en place nos dispositifs de sécurité
madame la sénatrice donc sur le le oui
on on a connaissance évidemment parce
que d'abord moi j'ai des collaborateurs
qui sont allés à Londres he voir comment
les choses s'étaient passées pour avoir
des rtex on travaille beaucoup avec le
CIO aussi hein qui d'ailleurs qui est
qui est là en ce moment le président est
là en ce moment et demain nous planchons
avec Monsieur Michel cade le délégué
interministè le jeu lui et moi allons
plancher sur ces sujets devant le CO qui
a échéance régulière vient nous demander
comment les choses ch avance comment ça
se passe et ce qu'ils nous disent je je
le répète parce que ce ce qu'il nous
disent c'est que nous sommes
parfaitement dans les délais sur les
questions de sécurité et tout sur tous
les autres sujets mais moi je parle de
ce que je connais et qu'il n'y a pas de
difficulté particulière il faut bien
l'avoir en tête et le CIO dans d'autres
capitales contrairement à ce que j'ai pu
entendre ces jours derniers il y a eu
aussi des restrictions de circulation
bien plus lourdes que celles que nous
mettons en place hein donc voilà et et
et quand on n anticipe pas les choses
les restrictions se mettent parfois
d'ell-même en place dans les faits de
facto elles se mettent en place donc
voilà donc on travaille beaucoup avec le
CIO euh on a beaucoup de retour
d'expérience aussi de leur part sur des
événements euh qui qui qui euh qui
peuvent avoir des impacts sur la
sécurité mais qui sont liés finalement à
la vie olympique nous connaî pas
forcément cette vie olympique les Jeux
Olympiques euh des d'entre les transport
d'athlètes la façon dont se comportent
les délégations et cetera donc il nous
donne beaucoup d'informations oui et on
a on a des échanges vraiment voilà on a
le rétex de tous les jeux et les
échanges sont sont très fluides sur la
durée de conservation des données c'est
celle de l'arrêté c'est le maximum 3
mois mais en général enfin pour ce genre
de pour ce genre de plateforme on n pas
besoin d'une durée très très longue hein
voilà c'est le maxi est prévu par la par
l'arrêté c'est 3 mois après bon les les
vous avez quandême une période de jeu
qui qui qui qui qui fait entre dans la
zone de Paris Centre entre la cérémonie
d'ouverture euh et donc le dispo qui va
se mettre en place plusieurs jours avant
et la fin des jeux avec les
paralympiques on est quand même sur une
période qui fait un mois et demi là un
bon mois et demi donc voilà mais dans
d'autres zones ce sera moins nécessaire
de il y a des sites d'ailleurs qui n'ont
vocation qu'à exister que pour les les
Jeux Olympiques et qu'on ne retrouve pas
donc pour les Jeux paralympiques hein
donc Jeux Olympiques jeux paralympiqu il
y a deux sites qui disparaissent
notamment le Trocadero et un site dans
le
92 merci Monsieur le Préfet merci merci
chers collègues la séance est
levée